cher françois fillon cher luc chatel
président de notre conseil national
monsieur le premier ministre sheikh
edouard balladur monsieur le premier
ministre
cher jean pierre raffarin chers amis
c'est un honneur pour moi de m'adresser
à vous de le faire en tant que
secrétaire général de notre mouvement et
je dois d'abord remercié françois fillon
de m'avoir confié cette responsabilité
que j'exerce accompagné de mes deux
secrétaires généraux adjoints
gérald darmanin et annie genevard et
avec deux vice présidents laurent
wauquiez et isabelle le gall nerfs
je veux aussi saluer très amicalement
chacune et chacun d'entre vous vous mes
amis parlementaires et élus jouent cadre
de nos fédérations vous conseillers
nationaux vous candidats et candidates
aux élections législatives des 11 et 18
juin
et vous chers militants républicains de
paris de nos 180 des rations venus de
paris de toute la france de la métropole
d'outre-mer et aussi les représentants
des pensées de l'étranger
les 20 et 27 novembre c'est vous cadres
et militants qui avaient été les
artisans de cette grande réussite
démocratique qu'a été la primaire de la
droite et du centre
je veux vous en remercier c'est aussi la
force unique que constitue notre grande
famille des républicains
rassemblant la droite et le centre qui a
permis ce succès cette famille elle a
été la volonté et la concrétisation de
jacques chirac en 2002
les républicains issus de l'ump notre
famille qui doit tant à son fondateur
comme à celui qui l'a remise sur pied
nos deux amis deux hommes d'état le
premier qui a servi notre pays avec un
dévouement que nul n'a atteint alain
juppé
le second qui lui aussi s'est donné
totalement à la france dont il a été le
président de la république respecte et
qui à protéger notre pays et l'europe
dans les pires conditions écrit nicolas
sarkozy
grâce à votre dévouement par deux fois
quatre millions trois cent mille
électeurs de la droite et du centre ont
pu s'exprimer et désigner très
clairement pour l'élection
présidentielle des 23 avril et 7 mai
notre candidat françois villon on
sautille ont choisi par les électeurs de
la primaire comme l'épreuve à nos
statuts est donc devenu le président de
notre mouvement
françois nous te connaissons je te
connais depuis longtemps
nous connaissons ses qualités humaines
de travail de fidélité d'honnêteté
nous connaissons l'homme politique l'élu
l'homme d'état et nous sommes avec toi
derrière le gaulliste social que tu es
mais si notre candidat bénéficie ainsi
d'un avantage d'une dynamique importante
pour autant la route est encore longue
et piégeuse jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle alors que la paix
mondiale n'a jamais été aussi menacé
depuis la fin de la guerre froide alors
que l'europe trébuche comme jamais
depuis le traité de rome tandis que la
france est confrontée à une situation
d'une gravité inconnu depuis la fin de
la quatrième république
notre pays a besoin d'un chef d'état à
la hauteur de ces défis angoissant un
homme d'état porteur d'un projet de
véritables ruptures pour enfin
interrompre la spirale infernale d'un
déclin qui s'accélère
notre pays a besoin d'une analyse lucide
de la situation critique dans laquelle
il se trouve
notre pays a besoin d'un projet
courageux de réforme à la hauteur des
défis auxquels nous sommes confrontés
c'est analyse ce projet ils sont portés
par françois fillon
le projet de françois fillon est
audacieux porteurs de profondes réformes
justement parce que la france a besoin
de réformes et de courage le projet de
françois fillon est fondée sur la vérité
car la vérité est toujours moins
violente que le mensonge
a priori nous pourrions sous-estimé le
candidat d'une gauche affaibli par ses
divisions et fracassé après cinq années
de présidence
hollande un président qui a été élu en
2012 sur le déni de la crise mondiale et
sur des promesses mensongères
un président qui abandonne une france
confrontée à de multiples grave crise
crise économique et sociale chez pure
iter financière morale et crise
politique
mais sous-estimé la gauche serait une
erreur car en fait le candidat de la
gauche c'est monsieur macron monsieur
vaqueront ce fils parricide de françois
hollande dont il a été l'inspirateur de
la catastrophique politiques fiscales et
économiques dont il a été le ministre de
l'économie
un ministre dont nous découvrons
l'étendue et la gravité des erreurs aux
dépens des fleurons de notre industrie
reniant son positionnement politique et
son pitoyable bilan c'est-à-dire le
bilan de françois hollande
monsieur macron voudrait faire croire
qu'il va sauver notre pays alors qu'ils
ne conduit qu'à une opération de
marketing politique mensongère
de l'autre côté à l'extrême droite
madame le pen n'en finit pas de copier
le programme économique social et anti
européens de l'extrême gauche celui d'un
populisme démagogues et dangereux oui
mes chers amis
notre responsabilité est immense car il
n'ya que notre candidat et son projet
pour la france qui puisse relever le
défi national et international notre
détermination pour faire gagner françois
fillon sera totale il n'y a désormais
plus de place pour les états d'âme plus
de place pour les tergiversations ou les
stratégies personnelles
nous n'en avons pas le droit nos
compatriotes ne le mérite pas il nous le
ferait payer très cher à tous et pour
longtemps
mes chers amis je vous appelle donc tous
à cette unité condition première de la
victoire ce n'est pas en allant critiqué
publiquement le programme de notre
candidat en prétendant la main sur le
coeur qu'il faut juste en changer sur
tel ou tel point
ce n'est pas en persistant à faire de la
fin du cumul des mandats un sujet aussi
important que la situation de la france
ce n'est pas ainsi que nous réussirons à
atteindre notre objectif la victoire
une victoire un objectif que nous
partageons tous et que nous devons tous
partager
quand on a une suggestion à faire un
autre candidat qui est ici c'est à lui
que nous le faisons pas devant un micro
c'est cela qui différencie l'action
individuelle au service d'une stratégie
personnelle de l'intérêt collectif au
service de notre candidat de ces
millions de français qui nous ont fait
confiance au service de notre pays
à chaque fois qu'ils entendent nos voix
dissonantes
il ne tous comprennent pas nos
compatriotes c'est cela qui peut mettre
à mal une dynamique de campagne
c'est aussi cela qui éloigne de nous nos
propres électeurs c'est cela qui ruine
la crédibilité des responsables
politiques et nourrit l'abstention et
les votes protestataires
chers amis vous qui êtes coeur battant
de notre famille politique
vous l'avez compris votre engagement
irréprochable et total pour la campagne
de françois fillon sera décisif la
victoire le 7 mai de notre candidat
dépend aussi de nous je compte sur vous
pour que françois fillon devient le
huitième président de la cinquième
république et qui à nouveau
vive la france
maintenant j'ai le plaisir de laisser la
parole à nouveau de lisser la parole à
luc ch affaire luc chatel et le
président de notre conseil national
c'est un homme dont nous apprécions tous
les qualités chez l'artisan du
rassemblement chez celui qui avec toute
sa loyauté et son ardeur conduit notre
conseil national un soutien unanime à
françois fillon
luc chatel
[Applaudissements]